Right. Next up, I'm here on slide 17, and we're going to have a quick look at something
that's called custom data. Again, this is a relatively new element, but it can be updated
and used at runtime. So you can see that we have five different colored balls in
this section. The interesting thing about this is all of them are using exactly the
same material, this m underscore custom primitive data. The only thing that's changing on any
of these is we are using custom primitive data, which is a variable which is saved on a mesh
or skeletal mesh, and we are using that in the material in order to change the color.
So let's have a look at the material. So you can see here, I only have one node in
this and that's custom primitive data. Now, in order to create something like this, what
you would need to do is you need to create a parameter such as a scalar and select, you
see down the bottom, you have select custom data primitive, and that will allow you to
tick the box, and it will also allow you to define the index. And I'll show you
this on the other side. But if we have a look at the one that's already created,
it's a vector four, and we are using custom primitive data, and we're using the index
of zero. So it starts at zero. But you can create a lot more, you can create a whole
load of them to control a whole load of different things. Now, if we were to look
at each of these, you can see if I search for custom primitive data, oops, custom primitive
data, you'll see here, we have color. So that color is set to red. If I was to jump
to the next one, you can see it's set to green and blue and yellow. And if I was
to change any of these, you'd see that the color updates instantaneously. So we
are using the custom primitive data to inform the material. But the nice thing
about custom primitive data is we can change them at runtime. So let's have a quick
look at that in action. So what I've got here is a few nice, I think they're dragons,
but they're called dinosaurs. They've got wings, they're not dinosaurs. So let's have a look
at this in action now. So if you come to slide 18, and press ALT P to play, and I'll see
that we got these dinosaur-esque dragon creatures. If you fire up all of them, you can
run. So let's have a look at how this is done. Now the dragons themselves, we
don't actually need to do any code in them at all. We're doing all of this
within the projectile. So the main piece of code that we're looking at, if
we were to break this down on construction script, I randomly generated
a little color, a little bit over convoluted for what's needed. And then when the projectile
hits something, it casts the dragon to check that it is. And if it is, it will just
set the custom primitive data value on the drug. So again, it's just another method
of updating materials at runtime. The other nice thing about custom primitive data is
you can have numerous colors and then they're not seen as
unique materials. They're all put together in the same render pin. So they
will all be rendered as a singular material. And that makes it far better
than something like a dynamic material, where if you had a hundred dragons, they
would all have to have their own dynamic material, which would all have to
be rendered independently. Where in this case, all of these dragons, they can be
any color you're using, and they'll all be rendered as a single material, a single
draw call. OK, so that is the custom primitive data.